i've been doing it too much that man  right there got the best job security in  the history of civilization right there  who's that scottie boss john is on to  comupo  as long as as long as his brother is the  man he gonna have a job  he gonna have a job he's not a bad  player i know i didn't say he was a bad  player but i'm saying they know they're  not job security they got for job  security that boy gonna always have a  job as long as his brother's the man  i've been doing too much that man right  there got the best job security in the  history of civilization right there  who's that scotty bong john is on to  kamufo  as long as as long as his brother is the  man he gonna have a  he gonna job a job he's not a bad player  i know i didn't say he was a bad player  but i'm saying they know they're not  going off security they got for job  security that boy gonna always have a  job as long as his brother's the man